[Music]
starwars
belongs to everyone who loves this
amazing universe we've all grown up with
it and now we add eyes have the
opportunity of a lifetime to make the
Star Wars game that as fans with all
dreamt of playing
to stay as true to the films as possible
we went back to it all began visiting
the Lucas archives to capture the actual
models and props used in the movies was
an incredibly emotional experience
there's so much love and detailed in
these pieces that we want to get into
the game
but to immerse players in iconic Star
Wars battles will take more than just
authentic weapons and vehicles we went
to the original movie locations not just
to capture the environments but the
emotions they involved as well the early
results are truly spectacular
[Music]
we have an experienced team an
extraordinary collaboration with
Lucasfilm
and some of the best technology in the
industry
but above all it is our passion for Star
Wars that will bring this legacy to life
like never before
[Music]
and as someone once said do or do not
there is no try
[Applause]
[Music]